andorra is a landlocked nation situated
right between spain and france
whom as you'll know both have a history
of expansion and conquering whatever
wasn't nailed down
despite its expansionist neighbours
andorra has managed to exist for over
750 years
which raises the question why why does
andorra exist
so to grossly oversimplify as of the
12th century the lands that made up
pandora were controlled by the church
and under the jurisdiction of the bishop
of virgil
now the church struggled to defend its
land and so the bishop of herzl turned
to the lords of cabo
to do the defending for them an
agreement was reached in that the lords
of cabo would be given the rights to tax
and conscript men in the region whereas
the church would retain ownership of
them these feudal rights soon went to
the council foie which is here and they
in the church had a good working
relationship
for about 50 years which was when the
sitting counterfoil started to pinch a
bunch of land from the church and
incorporated it into foie proper there
was some squabbling and with the
intervention of the king of aragon the
two sides came to an agreement the count
of foie would return the land that he
took and in return the church wouldn't
excommunicate him
also both the counterfoir and the bishop
of urgel would from then on rule andorra
as co-princes
this arrangement had little change until
1479.
this was when the count of four francis
phoebus inherited the kingdom of navarre
on top of his other lands
and less than a century later king henry
iii of navarre became king henry iv for
france and thus from then on one of the
co-princes of andorra was also the ruler
of france
and this is one of those things that
actually helped to secure andorra
it was now under the protection of
france and king louis xiii soon after
incorporated into the remaining kingdom
of navarre the spanish didn't mind
andorra being moved closer to france
because they themselves had several
reasons not to want it
the first was that economically andorra
had very little to offer and second the
people there were sympathetic to the
catalonians during their rebellions
against spain and so from the spanish
king's perspective andorra's inclusion
would do little but making catalonia
larger
and third it didn't want to annoy the
church as you'll know the french
monarchy would eventually go through
some difficult
times and when the french revolution was
well underway french leaders opted to
leave
andorra to its own devices so now
andorra was on its own
it did not like this turn of events and
so when napoleon was crowned the emperor
of france the andorrans asked for him to
return as their co-prince which he
accepted and then three years later
annexed catalonia and incorporated
andorra into it
napoleon was soon defeated and andorra
went back to being co-ruled by the
french king
and after france was finally done with
monarchy the french president
this status yet again put antora under
the protection of france which is why
when the spanish civil war broke out it
was stationed by french troops to
protect it
when world war ii broke out andorra
declared itself to be neutral
which technically wasn't true since it
had previously declared war against
germany in the last world war and wasn't
invited to the treaty of versailles and
so never technically made peace
but even when vichy france was dissolved
and occupied germany didn't move into
andorra and in effect it remained
neutral
and after france was liberated the last
threat to andorra was gone and its
position as an independent nation were
secured thereafter
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette marvin cassell rob
waterhouse mo
james castaneda aaron the whites jordan
longley gustav swan
jerry lamdin marcus asner rasheed ali
miss izek coppertone spinning three
plates maggie paxkowski winston k wood
matthew shipley spencer lightfoot
anthony beckett lexi schwinn
robert wedsell corso wolf skye chappelle
and charles the first